[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 2 avril
une exposition autour d'henri ii est un
ballet sur la reine margot à saint
germain en les deux membres de la
famille des valois ont inspiré le musée
d'archéologie nationale et le
chorégraphe régis obadia un week-end
rien que pour lui pour clôturer le
printemps des poètes c'est le mot qui
était à l'honneur durant deux jours le
public a pu réfléchir au choix des mots
utilisés
une enquête qui vous entraînent de
rambouillet à nice pour son nouveau
roman l'auteur gilles milova série
s'inspire de la cité yvelinoise
l'ouvragé sorti le 22 mars dernier à
saint germain en laye la fin du mois de
mars rimer avec un anniversaire celui de
la naissance du roi henri ii en 15/100
19 au sein même du château un roi peu
connus souffrent d'une mauvaise image
injustifiée le musée d'archéologie
nationale lui consacre une exposition en
se mettant à l'heure de la renaissance
c'est un personnage on peut oublier le
roi henry deux araignées 12 ans de 15
147 à 459 12 ans pendant la renaissance
ou le château de saint germain prend une
certaine place le roi y passent en
moyenne 58 jours par an saint germain en
laye et naturellement le siège de
nombreuses décisions on prend des actes
politiques
il comprend également des actes
diplomatique les relations
internationales se nouent et se dénouent
à saint-germain-en-laye aurait donc de
l'évolution de la politique d'henri deux
ans nous avons à ce sujet la chance de
présenter ici prêté par le musée
national de la renaissance un objet tout
à fait extraordinaire qui est en forme
de livre avec une couverture et un
feuillet centrale pour cette exposition
le musée d'archéologie nationale
rassemble ils sont enders re découverte
de la personnalité du souverain
la production artistique de cette époque
et des instants marquants du règne qui
démarre sous des tensions entre son
entourage et celui de son père l'une de
ces tensions s'est incarné dans le 2l
fameux qui a opposé approche de futurs
henry 2 qui est encore dauphin qui
s'appelle la châtaigneraie et un proche
de la duchesse d'étampés la maîtresse de
françois 1er
le baron de jarnac beau-frère de la
butte
une tension qui amènera un duel entre
les deux hommes peu de temps après
l'accession au trône de henry de jarnac
donnera son fameux court aux jarrets de
la châtaigneraie
c'est la première exposition consacrée à
ce roi une mise en lumière d'un
souverain éclipsé par son père et son
entourage son épouse catherine de
médicis ou encore sa fille marguerite de
valois la reine margot et on va
justement s'intéresser à elle la reine
margot la fille d'henri 2 avec un balai
actuellement en création à saint germain
en laye là aussi patrick jacques de
dixmude à la technique
quand on parle de la reine margot on
pense au roman d'alexandre dumas ou
encore l'interprétation d'isabelle
adjani dans le long métrage de patrice
chéreau met la vie de marguerite de
valois ne cesse d'inspirer les artistes
le chorégraphe régis obadia s'est lancé
dans l'aventuré
à la demande du théâtre alexandre dumas
de saint germain en laye régis obadia
bonjour bonjour
déjà pourquoi la reine margot benoît
dissaux qui est programme la saison au
théâtre travaille au cirque à chaud je
travaille clé depuis douze ans et il m'a
parlé des 30 ans du théâtre alexandre
dumas et donc je connais le théâtre déjà
passé avec la dame aux camélias ici à
deux trois ans et en regardant le
théâtre j'ai vu le château à côté
et l'idée m'est venue tout simplement de
tous partir du roman d'alexandre dumas
pour monter reine margot c'est vraiment
le roman qui vous a donné ce fil
conducteur c'est un roman qui vous
plaisait il ya le roman il ya le film de
chéreau donc voilà reine margot cédant
nos dans notre inconscient on va dire
maintenant le roman est très épais moi
je fais un spectacle de danse d'une
heure dix 1h15 donc c'est sûr qu'on
s'est vraiment concentré sur les
événements essentiels du roman et
surtout voilà l'énergie qu'on peut
ressentir à travers ce récit par les
personnages de l'histoire on y connaît
tous des grands noms de l'histoire de
france marguerite de valois j'ai dit à
leurs catherine 2006 henri de navarre
pour ne citer que c'est des personnages
forts
comment on les avait demandé à vos
danseurs des interprètes donc en fait
dans la pièce on est dans la danse
contemporaine
donc c'est une narration mais c'est pas
une narration classique donc il ya par
moments je pense que les gens vont
reconnaître les personnages par un
moment il interdit il incarne un
caractère un personnage entre guillemets
et à d'autres moments
ils sont ils sont plus abstrait c'est le
langage c'est la danse qui parle
voilà les mêmes codes sont dans le
caractère y danse oui il ya deux il ya
un peu de lecture
vous parlez des émotions des sensations
c'est quand même une histoire très dur
l'histoire de margaux comment vous
l'aviez mise en scène c'était peut-être
cette violence qui vous a inspiré façon
je pense que depuis que l'être humain
est sûre terrienne certaine violence
depuis toujours c'est vrai que cette
époque est vraiment redoutable d'un
autre est pas mal aussi
donc voilà ça fait partie de nous l'être
humain est comme ça la vie est un
miracle et en même temps c'est une
tragédie
on vit avec donc voilà il ya des
émotions assez fort justement pour j'ai
pu pour j'ai pu m'en imprégner m'ont
inspiré de travailler après avec les
danseurs
[Musique]
vous avez dû peut-être échangé beaucoup
avec eux pour peut-être parfois souffler
face aux émotions qui arrive
vous savez le travail de création c'est
vraiment un cheminement particulier chez
moi ça fait près de quarante ans que je
fais des spectacles échappe fox une
nouvelle pièce on a vraiment la
sensation nous repartir à zéro sachant
qu'on a un certain métier mais quand
même un show passer une remise en
question alors à la mise en scène vous
êtes accompagné de lisa viargues aso va
un mot sur cette sauvage que j'ai
rencontrés depuis pratiquement 20 ans et
sans elle tout ça n'existerait pas parce
qu'elle apporte énormément c'est elle
qui fait les choix musicaux celles qui
décident qui fait les costumes la
dramaturgie là je travaille depuis
beaucoup de danseurs russes
moi je parle russe mais très peu donc
c'est vrai que quand je dois expliquer
quelque chose d'un peu plus profonde
celle qui leur parle on est vraiment en
osmose quoi elle est vraiment très très
important dans le dans mon travail
injustement au niveau de la mise en
scène on va dire plutôt de théâtre s'est
choisi un espace dépouillé c'était aussi
pour laisser toute la place à la danse
et à l'interprétation de vovo danseurs
sait aussi que donc moi nous manger neuf
danseurs et il ya aussi un travail avec
le 25 danseurs amateurs de saint germain
donc on va être prêt de 40 sur le
plateau donc je pense qu'elle 40 sur le
plateau on n'a pas besoin encore de
rajouter un décor donc il ya des
éléments scéniques qui sont cycliques
symbolique et je pense que ça suffit
pour donner pour raconter ce qu'on a
envie de dire et ça travaille juste ou
moins que les amateurs comment il s'est
déroulé ce que vous n'avez peut-être les
mêmes exigences qu'elle vaut
professionnels là bas je crois qu'on va
être le théâtre alexandre dumas
pratiquer la danse examens durent depuis
un certain temps dans règle générale le
corps d'anne fait une pièce spécifique
pour des amateurs
et moi ce que j'ai proposé c'est
d'impliquer des amis
donc y en a peut-être un peu moins que
d'habitude d'habitude 140 et d'avoir
avec eux exactement la même exigence que
je peux avoir avec les danseurs
professionnels
donc les filles sont venues
je pense que ça leur plaît qu'elles sont
motivées elles n'ont pas toutes le même
niveau tout cas on a certaines qui en
font moins que d'autres mais celles qui
seront sur le plateau elles doivent
exister vraiment comme les autres et
pour ça je pense que c'est un challenge
vraiment nouveau par rapport au travail
avec des amateurs du côté de la musique
vous mais les contemporains de
l'histoire contemporain d'aujourd'hui
comment vous l'avez pensez donc la
musique comme jouer tout à l'heure les à
viriat sauva beaucoup de patience et
elle recherche des nuits entières la
musique parce que la musique pour la
danse c'est essentiel c'est vraiment moi
ça m'inspire ça nous fait partir d'un
direction différente ça donne vraiment
une couleur et une scène est donc dans
ce spectacle est aussi bien des musiques
on va dire contemporaine hien
hervo parti a redit aux ide tout ça
c'est des auteurs contemporains et il ya
bach monteverdi donc voilà donc ça c'est
tout ça se chevauchent et donne un monde
en soi
merci les alors la première de votre
création à reine margot est à voir au
théâtre alexandre dumas de saint germain
en laye le jeudi 11 avril à 20h45 ce
week-end clôturer le printemps des
poètes et à cette occasion
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mettait le mot
à l'honneur deux jours d'ateliers de
causeries de conférences lui était
consacrée à la commanderie grégory canal
et des mots d'ici démo de là-bas à la
commanderie on ne parlait que d'eux les
mots ont eu leur premier village
entièrement dédié ce week-end le mot
c'est d'abord la communication c'est une
manière entre nous de communiquer mais
le mot quel qu'il soit je veux dire que
ce soit de notre langue ou d'autres
langues
il est important et je pense important
de savoir quels mots choisir le poids du
monde et il est essentiel de choisir le
bon mot au bon moment plutôt que
d'entendre d un peu tout et n'importe
quoi au niveau du langage
[Musique]
deux jours pour développer la créativité
51 des bus-navettes invités
conférencière orthophoniste poète et
calligraphe le mot c'est ce qui
constitue pour nous la poésie la
calligraphie de mots composés de
plusieurs lettres
donc nous on a on apprend quand on
commence notre apprentissage
on commence par la lettre les justement
dans les démarches de l'apprentissage la
lettre tout seul la lettre est attachée
et le mot donc c'est vraiment notre et
dernière étape la place du mot n'était
pas n'importe laquelle dans une phrase
il fallait que le mot tombe bien qu'ils
aient le dernier mot
éventuellement l'amour la langue
française partagez la langue française
qui est plein de ressources
plein de mots avec lesquels on peut
jongler donc raymond avait l'art de
mettre le mot là où il fallait pour que
ce soit le petit grain de sable qui
dérègle la mécanique
le village du mot clôturer le printemps
des poètes une vingtaine de rendez-vous
était programmé autour d'un thème celui
de la beauté suivre ses rêves ses
passions c'est le message que
l'écrivaine ingrid thobois a voulu faire
passer auprès d'une classe du lycée jean
vilar de plaisir près d'une heure des
changes pour partager ses inspirations
ses voyages il est au bois lors a aussi
parlé d'un auteur qui l'a marqué les
collabos vié qui a vraiment été pour moi
un moteur dans mon existence extrêmement
important et comme je dis à chaque fois
que je parle de nicolas bouvier sans
cette rencontre avec son oeuvre il était
décédé dont je n'ai pas rencontré lui
donc sans cette rencontre avec ses
livres j'aurais probablement eu une vie
très différente
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on reçoit un
auteur au lycée dans le cadre des leçons
de littérature qui sont en fait un
proposé par la région ile-de-france au
lycée donc on a répondu présent et on a
eu cette année encore un auteur qui est
venu faire sa leçon les propos ont été
recueillis par aurélie rose et on
continue cette sculpture avec un invité
gilles milova série bonjour pour soir
mélanie alors vous êtes vous aussi
écrivain est ce qu'il faisait déjà rêver
d'aller à la rencontre de lycéens et de
collégiens tout à fait que ce soit
faculté des étudiants dans tous de tous
les niveaux et c'est très intéressant
c'est important aussi d'aller à la
rencontre du public oui important dans
le lecteur bien entendu mais mais voilà
les enfants je les fais des séances dans
des écoles primaires
je vous jure que c'est vraiment du
bonheur pour un écrivain parce que vous
avez des gens qui sont à tulle en cash
sans filtre et on passe des superbement
et j'ai souvent dans cette rencontre
leur a conseillé de suivre leurs rêves
est ce que c'est un conseil que vous
donneriez aussi un gène sinon je serais
pas là oui tout à fait suivre ses rêves
c'est important c'est des choses des
choses à faire dans la vie il faut c'est
même plus que les suivants c se l'est
fixé comme une des buts précis attendre
alors si vous êtes avec nous ce soir
c'est pour présenter votre nouvel
ouvrage les printemps très les
prêtresses pardon d'altaï à elles nous
font suivre un ancien commandant de la
dgs et angelina aussi tout à fait alors
pas trop trop vous en dire mais j'avais
j'avais une série qui aime bien
fonctionné qui est beaucoup plus en
thriller et là j'avais envie de revenir
au roman sombre le polar pur et dur donc
comme rambouillet a été une ville
importante pour moi mais j'ai décidé
d'implanter cette agence dans lequel
privé auprès de rambouillet est donc cet
ancien commandant des fsi va mener une
enquête particulière quand on vous dira
c'est une recherche de personne distante
voilà mais j'en dirai pas plus pas plus
sur l'histoire main peut-être un peu
plus sur angelina est une femme
indépendante forte et pourtant vous
indiquer qu'elle n'est pas la meilleur
de sa profession vous n'avez pas voulu
une héroïne parfaite
non surtout pas je voulais pas vous
savez on tombe souvent dans les
les archétypes avec des héros ou des
héroïnes qui vont être c'est le sait la
belle femme s'est levée l'homme s'est
plaint de chou c'est ça n'existe pas
dans le dip donc la angelina c'est
quelqu'un qui est une femme séduisante
mais qui est pas inquiet palme à cannes
comme on peut dire c'est une femme qui a
quitté la police pour des raisons bien
précises qui soit expliqué dans ce
premier opus et surtout c'est que c'est
une femme moderne qui a divorcé qui est
célibataire et qui qui mène sa vie entre
les soucis de la bombe que qui appellent
régulièrement et puis des enquêtes à
mener donc j'ai vraiment voulu
l'intégrer dans un dans un schéma de
crédible voilà un personnage qu'on
pourrait croiser des gens même si on
croise peut-être rarement des les
anciens agents d'aller chez fait alors
le début du roman se passe dans une
ville yvelinoise rambouillet pourquoi
rambouillet rabouillé parce que des gens
en 2016 il y avait eu la terre es mon
précédent roman qui se déroulait dans
cette ville et j'ai été magnifiquement
est cueilli par cette ville que ce soit
la municipalité où les rangs boli temps
j'ai gardé un merveilleux souvenir et je
voulais les remercier et c'est pour leur
dire un grand grand merci que j'ai
décidé de relancer une seconde série qui
va se dérouler donc sur rambouillet
renvoyer vous apportez du mystère si
pour écrire ses romans la wii mais c'est
une ville que j'apprécie parce que c'est
une ville qui est qui et moderne est qui
et qui rentrent dedans comme un certain
classicisme en plus avec 2 a passé riche
en histoire et c'est fabuleux
donc oui pour un auteur c'est celle où
un endroit rêvé pour l'écrire alors dans
vos romans vous aimez faire voyager
voyager vos personnages et pour les
prêtresses d'altaïr en général jusqu'à
berne elle à partir à berne pour des
raisons bien précises
de cette histoire de bernad à repartir
sur de la côte d'azur à nice
edonys elle va revenir 1re oublier pour
clôturer ce manque est clore ce manque
est alors on parlait tout à l'heure de
patrons dévoilé mais dans le titre il ya
al tahir al tahrir c'est une étoile est
ce que c'est un indice pour l'histoire
mais bon c'est en fait voilà c'est un
nom bien bien précis qu'il a représenté
un personnage symbolique dans l'histoire
et qui va être que des phases de la
recherche importante que damon et
angelina c'est difficile parce que ce
serait ce pas il est un petit peu
l'histoire de vous en dire beaucoup plus
mais voilà je remets nom poétique et
pourtant point de suspension a justement
pour en découvrir un petit peu plus
on peut vous rencontrer le 6 avril le
public peut venir vous voir faire
dédicacer peut-être ou échanger sur les
ouvrages tout à fait marc robert donc
m'a fait l'amitié de mettre des moyens
vraiment très très sympathique et on va
se retrouver là seule la lanterne
on a cherché de la lanterne à
rambouillet où je vais faire une
conférence débat avec les lecteurs qu'il
soit dix pendant une petite heure et
après pendant trois heures et demie je
serai en dédicace toujours dans la salle
de la lanterne et ce sera un moment
pendant sympa alors vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure il s'agit d'un premier
opus porté sur une saga est ce que il ya
déjà des dates de sorties les ouvrages
ont mûri et sont déjà écrits et curieuse
très curieuse le deuxième va sortir sur
le troisième trimestre 2010 9
voilà c'était la surprise la surprise du
jour parce que parce que l'éditrice a
apprécié le livre les premiers retours
sont très bons
donc je touche du bois et et on
déjà dans ma tête il est pratiquement
écrit donc ce sera troisième trimestre
pour ses ouvrages vous fait beaucoup de
recherches parce que je pense notamment
à meurtre à chaque château arnoux vous
nous emmenez pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale où il faut avoir un sacré
bagage historique aussi vous aimez aussi
mêlé le présent le passé
oui parce que j'ai fait j'ai fait du
polar thriller et de l'historique si
vous voulez écrire des histoires qui
vont vous les voulez crédible il faut à
tout prix faire beaucoup beaucoup de
recherches je défends préalable donc
avant l'écriture est là il faut il
passer beaucoup de temps on n'a pas la
science infuse et si vous commettez une
erreur dans un roman aux policiers les
lecteurs qui sont assidus eux ils vont
pas me louper et qui s'y connaissent
peut-être anticipant les farces et
peut-être même encore pire en histoire
merci j'ai mis l'ovale série alors je le
rappelle vous êtes écrivain et votre
ouvrage les prêtresses d'altaïr est
sorti aux éditions du 38
un dernier mot de littérature le 4 avril
prochain le musée de la toile de jouy
vous permet de rencontrer sébastien pâle
l'écrivain vous entraîne à travers le
destin de deux personnalités deux
immigrés à lima une jeune sénégalaise et
christophe oberkampf un terrier allemand
protestants le créateur de la fameuse
toile de jouy quels sont les enjeux
européens actuels qu'est ce que l'europe
des questions auxquelles vous n'avez pas
toutes les réponses et une compagnie a
décidé d'en faire une pièce les têtes de
l'art était à saint germain en laye pour
un procès théâtralisée nicolas landry
pour les images jugées l'europe sur le
banc des accusés déception et y sent son
rejet pour certains ennuis désintérêt
pour d'autres depuis 60 ans elle fait
débat un débat qui a inspiré la
compagnie les têtes de l'art je voulais
écriteau après les dernières élections
européennes de 2014
tout simplement je me suis posé une
question très simple c'est je suis
consterné par les résultats de la
dernière élection
qu'est-ce que moi en tant que citoyen et
en tant que directeur d'une structure
artistique et culturelle qu'est ce que
je peux faire sur ce sujet là et en fait
je ne suis pas expert qui ne fut pas
associations qui travaillent sur les
questions européennes je ne suis pas élu
politique mais par contre mes armes
c'est l'art inspiré par des proches à
son tribunal des flagrants délires
l'europe à la barre mêle fiction et
réalité avec une procureure un avocat de
la défense et un juge pragmatique en
prenant le public pour témoins moi c'est
le point de vue des citoyens que je
défends et donc l'europe a de très beaux
projets généralement a donc il n'est pas
question de savoir si si l'europe doit
être ou ne pas être elle est là par
contre qui elle défend qui elle protège
est ce qu'on y prend parce qu'on n'y
comprend quelque chose niveau de lyon
nous en tant que citoyens les
incohérences parfois entre ses
fondements
le fantasme européen et ce qui se passe
dans la réalité élections avant l'heure
mais pour nous l'enjeu ils étaient atral
et ça c'est très important c'est que
pour nous l'enjeu c'est de faire poser
des questions aux gens et de pas donné
de réponse on passe notre temps à
écouter des réponses sur l'europe ce
qu'elle doit être que doit pas être
nous ce qu'on veut c'est réinterroger
sur l'europe et les gens seraient
intéressés ce sujet un procès pour mieux
défendre cette europe à quelques
semaines du scrutin européen
la représentation était organisée par la
maison de l'europe des yvelines
[Musique]
quel est l'envers du décor que se
passe-t-il du côté des lumières du son
des costumes le chorégraphe christian
risofé marcher l'imagination du public
et que sa création d'à côté il est au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
3 au 6 avril
[Musique]
des anecdotes improbable sur sa vie sur
les rencontres incroyables qu'il a pu
faire il sait raphaël mezrahi et
l'humoriste et sur la scène de l'espace
albert camus ne mord pas ce samedi 6
avril dans un nouveau spectacle
allez allez allez allez allez allez
vas-y il a dit qu'un touriste walid au
stade tous quelques amis j'arrive à me
préparer une journée d'art dans un lieu
inédit le 6 avril prochain l'aérodrome
de javené vipre accueille une journée
des artistes à l'organisation
l'association audace
au programme des trios des duos des
conférences et des performances jamais
deux sans trois les tutus mon revient
pour un troisième numéro pourrir à
nouveau au prisme avec les talents
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
rendez vous le mardi 6 avril les pokemon
crew s'interroge sur la société du tout
numérique et des réseaux sociaux de
l'émerveillement à la méfiance hashtag
2.0
c'est la nouvelle création du collectif
de hip hop à découvrir à saint cyr
l'école
extraits
[Musique]
il
où
après une représentation à maurepas les
voilà sur la scène de la verrière vivre
debout black blanc beur et le théâtre du
sable rejoue leur spectacle prise en
compte mais en 2014
sur scène des personnes en situation de
handicap des professionnels et des
amateurs
rendez vous à 20h30 au scarabée et un
dernier rendez vous avant de nous
quitter l'atelier d'arts plastiques de
maurepas présente ses oeuvres au café de
la plage de la ville cette année les
adhérents ont travaillé sur d'autres
thématiques
vu du ciel et transparence c'est la fin
de ce set une culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]